[Music]
okay like to welcome you to to the
opening class tonight we're gonna go
over an opening called the rui lopez it
spelled ru y el ope Z it's named after
Spanish bishop from the 1590s he was the
first one he wrote a book about it
actually and it became very popular it's
considered the strongest opening for
white where both sides start with pawn
to King four two squares in front of the
King so it's a very good opening to know
you know the there are only two american
world champions right Bobby Fischer won
it in 1972 he was considered America's
best player ever and when he was real
champion he was considered the best
player in the whole world and a lot of
people thought he was the best player
that had lived up to that point in time
but to be honest with you they always
say that about the world champion he's
always the best that ever was but so
they've been lots of them
but there was only one other American
who was world champion before him do you
know who that was
well that was a Spanish bishop rival Pez
there was a guy from New Orleans back
before the Civil War in 1858 Paul Morphy
was 20 years old he was studying to be a
lawyer his dad was a judge and his
pastime was playing chess he was a child
prodigy he'd learned by watching his
parent his father and uncle play chess
and one time he corrected they made an
incorrect move and he spoke up and told
him that they'd made an incorrect move
and they couldn't believe it so they
checked it out decided he was right and
then they taught him more formally how
to play chess but he picked it up just
from watching them anyway when he was 20
he was too young to be a lawyer you had
to be 21 so he got invited to the first
United States Chess Championship in New
York City and he went up there and he
won the whole thing and they didn't they
they played little matches against the
other players so he played a guy named
Louis Paulson was a famous chess player
also and they played like four or five
games in Morphy won and he played other
guys but that's how they did it
and he did so well he won the tournament
that he got invited to go to Europe to
play the European chess masters in
England and France and Germany they
didn't have formal they didn't have very
many formal tournaments back then but
they did matches and each country had an
acknowledged champion so there was the
champion in England and then there were
like four or five other really good
players in England they had a champion
in France Germany the best player in
Europe was a German named ate off
Anderson he was a schoolteacher
mathematics but anyway the guy who is
nominally the best player in England was
Howard Staunton for whatever reason he
was the one that more if he wanted to
beat and he was the reason more if he
went to England first he tried to
arrange a match with Staunton and
starting that said come on up we'll play
but one morphic got there starting got
cold feet he was older he was writing
books and other things
apparently he decided it would hurt his
reputation if he played Paul Morphy and
lost so he kept putting the match off
and more if he was playing all these
other guys in England and beat him off
and then he got fed up with Staunton who
would never agree to a time for the
match he travelled over to France and
beat the guys in France and then the the
best player in Europe was in Germany
this ate off Anderson and he travelled
to France to play Murphy and that was
the best match more if he had because
that was the best player anyway they
call him the first unofficial world
champion because they didn't have a
title then but he was acknowledged to be
the best player in the world after he
wiped out all the European masters they
moved back New Orleans and tried to be a
lawyer he gave up just after that
because he thought it was interfering
with trying to be a lawyer so anyway he
went on but that's an interesting story
and he was the first of America first
and only American world champion told
Bobby Fischer and we had lots of
contenders over the years we had lots of
really good players but they weren't
quite able to get to the title but a lot
of country countries have good players
grandmasters but they've never had world
champions so it's fairly common in chess
so anyway tonight we're gonna I'm going
to show you this opening the Ray Lopez
now lets you probably know the Italian
game right are you familiar with the
Italian game all right let me show you
how that goes because we're gonna
digress a little bit this was the
opening that was played before the Ruhr
Lopez became popular when both sides
start with the King pond it's called the
double King pond the other main opening
is you've moved the pond in front of the
Queen two squares in black and that's
called double Queen pond now the double
King pond leads the most interesting
attacking it's more interesting than
pong the Queen for it turns out see how
neither pond is protected but if you
move the pond in front of the Queen it's
the ponds protected by the Queen it
turns out that that makes a big
difference in the way the opening goes
about soap on the Queen for by both
sides leads to a maneuvering game where
it stays complicated you don't trade
many ponds or pieces and they call it
positional chess where your jaw you're
trying to put your pieces in the best
squares but there aren't very that many
direct kings side attacks but pawn to
King four because the pawns aren't
protected they get traded off and it
opens up files for the Queen's and the
rooks and lines for the bishops see how
the pawns block the bishops initially so
you get a few of those pawns out of the
way and it opens up the whole board for
the pieces and that leads to really
strong attacks and interesting defenses
by black so when people start to play
chess they always recommend to start
with this because you learn how to do
attacking and defending chess later on
when you get better then you migrate and
start playing pawn to Queen four and you
start playing positional chess so anyway
but grandmasters of course play all the
different openings but these those are
the two most popular starting moves pawn
the King for Ampang the Queen for
there's only like two or three others
that are considered good the pawn in
front of the Queen Bishop goes up two
squares do you know what that openings
column
that's called the English opening it was
popularized back in the 1800s by English
players so so that would be this pawn
moving up see it's kind of to the side
of the board they and the sides in
Chester called wings and they're called
flanks like in an army the site is the
flank
so pawn the Queen Bishop or is called a
flank opening whereas the pawns in right
in the middle two are called the center
that those are the standard openings
okay so now that the Italian game so
anyway first you start with a pawn and
it lets your Bishop and Queen out and
see it's on the fourth row this is a
white side and this is black side now
what you want to do is you don't want to
attack with just say a knight and a
bishop this Bishop will come here in the
Italian game and attack this pawn only
defended by the King this pawn is the
weakest position in black starting
position because it's only defended by
the King a lot of beginners put the
bishop here and they move the knight
here they'll put the pawn here you it's
a mistake to move the pawn here and
block to the bishop so you always get
the bishop in front of the pawn then you
move the pawn up one Square to make a
pawn chain and it protects your key
center pot then this Bishop comes up and
protects this square so beginners like
to bring the knight here and then move
it up here with the bishop here they
threaten Knight takes pawn attacking the
Queen and rook or they can do Bishop
takes pawn check winning a pawn and the
King has to move to a bad square and
once the King moves you can't castle
right if the rook moves to you
castle either you also can't castle
through check or into check so if this
bishop was this Bishop was here this
pawn was gone so this line is open and
the knight and Bishop had moved
somewhere but black can't castle because
the King would end up on a square that's
check but let's say the this black
Bishop was here see how it goes to this
square
you can't castle through check see the
King moves two squares of network moves
here that's an you can't do that because
there's a check on this square as you're
moving this way that's called you can't
castle through check it'd be a bad move
anyway if you could do it
your Ric would land on a squared and the
bishop would take it the works worth
more than a bishop you guys know the
value of the pieces here's how its
here's how they do it it's very simple
because the pawn is the most worthless
piece but they're very useful they give
them arbitrarily a value of one then
they try to estimate how much each
pieces in terms of how many pawns it
would take to if you lost it you need so
a knight and Bishop you need three pawns
so their value of three a rook is a
value of five a queen is an is a nine a
queen is worth three two bishops on the
night or two nights and a bishop that's
the equivalent to a queen now two works
would be ten pawns or ten points they're
worth a little usually they're a little
stronger than a queen the King they
don't give a value two because the
object of the game is to checkmate the
King so you can't really you can't lose
the King so they don't bother giving him
a bad
you but the interesting thing about the
king he moves one score in any direction
right now in the beginning you said you
you want to tuck him behind these pawns
right here wouldn't you Castle right so
he's safe yeah but after all the queens
and knights and rooks are gone and it's
just King against King the King comes
out of his a little hole and tries to
attack pawns then the King is powerful
and in an ending let's say there's one
night on each side in the Kings the King
is considered stronger than a knight and
stronger than a bishop even though they
don't give it a value so it must be
worth at least four points and it's not
stronger than a rook now how do you
think they decided that a bishop is
three and the rook is five what do you
think the difference is why can't you
from a castle right that's the key point
a bishop is stuck on only one color so
if you're a king and your opponent white
is only as a bishop that's on a black
school you just put your King on a white
square but the rook can go to any
anything the other thing is the bishops
can only move on diagonals the rook can
do the whole file or a row he can go to
more squares and it's more valuable to
move on files and rows for attacking
purposes and like you said to go from
one point to another fast so those two
things combined more squares and they
can go to every color means they're
worth more now the knight in Bishop are
worth approximately the same but most
grandmasters feel the
most of the time Bishop's are a little
stronger than a knight but they don't
give it any higher value
they don't give fractional points like
they don't say the bishops 3.25 and the
Knights only three and then there are
certain accepted cases where the Knights
are stronger than bishops so here's a
case where the Knights stronger than a
bishop all the pawns are on the board
the bishops are blocked by the pawns but
the knight can hop over the pawns so the
knight can go end the knight can go to
any color square it just takes longer
because he moves them in l-shape only
three squares at a time but because he
can go to any color Square and hop over
the enemy pawns in his own pawns in that
case a knight is better than a bishop
but if if you take off a bunch of pawns
and you have a few left the bishops have
free run of the board and they can move
more squares than the little knights a
little slow you see and the bishop is
better than in the so this comes out in
the endgame the endgame you have the
opening right when you start off the
middle game and the ending the ending is
where you've traded off most pawns and
pieces you might have a knight and a
king and a few pawns evenly balanced
then it depends on who can attack and
win a pawn who wins the game and if
neither psyche you know you need to win
at least one pawn to win the chess game
if you neither side can win a pawn then
it's going to be a draw now the reason a
pawn is what you need is you eventually
shove it up and promote it to a queen
and if you can do that well then you
have a queen and it's easy to check make
your opponent so that's why a pawn is
usually enough but there are certain
endings where a key where White's a pawn
up and black just has the king and White
has a pawn but it's not automatically a
win for white
so let's say this pawn is the only pawn
and the white king is behind it and the
black King in front of it turns out
that's a draw to win the King has to be
in front of the pawn and forced the
black King back the pawn actually gets
in the way of the king of the Kings
behind the pawn and the court can't
force black back enough to win the game
so just some background alright so so
the main thing you want to do is you do
a pawn move just to kind of stake out
your territory then you want to make
peace every move you move a different
piece into play that's called rapid
development it's like in an army
you can't start an attack against an
opposing city or position until you get
your troops from the city you take them
by train or plane to the frontline
you're organizing it you get the food
equipment so in chess it's called
mobilization or rapid development so as
we go through the particular openings
it's all about moving the pieces out as
fast as you can and White has the
advantage of the first move because
White gets to move first now black has
to match white if black doesn't match
and falls behind so white gets three
pieces out and black only has one well
those three pieces can attack some point
and black can't defend because he
doesn't have his pieces mobilized and
can't move them to defend the key pawn
or whatever's attacked so as we go
through this opening notice that every
move by these grandmasters they're
bringing another piece or they're making
threats the ideal thing you make a move
with a piece and make a threat at the
same time if you make a threat it forces
your opponent it reduces his freedom of
movement he has to defend the threat if
he has to defend the threat
there's only one two or three ways he
can do that
see you limit his moves if you make if
he makes defensive moves and you're
attacking as white he can't attack you
you're safe you know what they call that
in chess the person who has the move in
is making the threats the chess term is
initiative the initiator of the chess
action okay so here's the next move for
white the knight comes out to f3 and
attacks the pawn that's not defended
that's the the best move for white it
attacks the pawn black has to defend the
pawn so how can black defend the pawn
there's that's one way there's other
ways what are the other ways the Queen
yeah yeah
well about the night can come out yeah
and the Queen could go up to squares and
protect it from this square right here
or here of course you can't go here
because the night would take it how do
you guys know chests notation yeah
numbers and letters so it's right here
this is algebraic the columns that
called files are lettered from A through
H and all the notation is done from the
white point of view every square has a
coordinate the rows are 1 through 8
so this pawn move see how it's on the
e-file
and it's on the fourth row to write this
down the move is e you do the file and
then the square the row for 4 that's
this and black moves his epon to this
which is the 5th row again coming up
here you see it right here so this is e
5 that the thing is when it's a pawn
move you don't have to put a P it's
understood if you don't write like a
knight is a capital N and the bishop is
the capital B and a Q capital Q and an R
capital R for work so when it's a pawn
move you see that you don't have to
write the P well if you move one of the
other pieces you have to put the capital
letter night and then the square f3 so
the night the only night that can go
this is f3 only one night can go there
this one goes to c3 now let's say this
night had moved before and was here on
d4 and this night was back here
now in that case this night can move
here or this night could move here it's
ambiguous you can't say into f3 if it's
ambiguous you have to give the starting
square so if it's this night you would
say Knight G to f3 and if it was the
night here it's on the D file you say nd
a f3 so that's uh that's out now
captures if you take let's say black
move the pawn here and you do pawn takes
pawn that's with an X and it would be e
pawn X D pawn e XD now if this Knight
was here and this Knight was here at
night took tonight it would be Knight X
and and X n castles is circle - circle
Castle queenside is three of them so
that notation you can follow us here on
the right and you see that they have the
names of the grandmasters that played at
the top these were between Russians
Peter Swift ler 2690 and vastly of
unchic 2711 they were in they've been in
the top ten or twenty of the world for
the last 25 years this game was played
way back in 2002 I think it was the
speed tournament speed game they caught
rapid so it wasn't a slow time but I I
picked it out because it demonstrates
the opening and they're there in the top
ten or 20 in the world all right so
anyway Black has to defend the pawn so
he put brings his knight to c6
okay now the now here's the
characteristic move of the really Lopez
the Bishop comes out and has the
potential to take the knight sometime in
the future
now the knight protects the pawn
when this bishop has the potential to
take the knight in chest they call that
pressure the bishop puts pressure on the
knight
now if the bishop takes the knight it's
called a capture or an exchange so at
some point in the future doesn't work
right now but let's say our white could
make another move in a row he kind of
threatened it looks like he threatens
Bishop takes Knight which defends the
pawn right so you take the knight away
the pawn is undefended this pawn takes
you what you wouldn't do this pawn
because you you do that this way so you
open the bishop line to the middle of
the board and you open the queen line if
you took this pawn you only opened a
line this way which isn't that good for
the bishop and the Queen's still blocked
by this pawn okay so Bishop takes Knight
pawn takes Knight takes pawn it looks
like that's White's threat so actually
this is the move that we're going to go
through pawn to Queen or three now if
white tries to win that pawn I'll show
you what happens so so far so good it
looks like white 1upon doesn't it but
notice that the knight and the pond
behind the knight are unprotected and
black can win the pawn back simply by
coming to this square attacking two
pieces that's in chess it's a double
attack it's very effective
the knight has two you would give up the
pawn before the knight
so the knight has to retreat the best
retreat is just to go back where it came
from threatening the Queen and then the
Queen takes the pawn and white has
nothing better than to trade Queens and
it's a dead even game so you see there
really isn't a threat yet of Bishop
takes Knight
but in the future it becomes a real
threat so that's kind of the idea that
underlies the beginning of this opening
the Rory Lopez is strong because it puts
pressure on blacks Knight that defends
blacks keep Ong and as more pieces
develop white actually does threatened
to take the knight and it forces black
to make pawn moves which weakened to
some extent his position and that gives
White's and possibility some possible
ways to play in the future what well
you'd have a hard time doing that
because you would expose your King to a
check you your Queens pinned as is
White's so there's nothing better than
Queen takes Queen check and you white
can't castles kings in the middle but
without the Queen's on the board you're
not going to be able to checkmate him
anyway so it's a dead draw it should be
a dead drop okay anyway going back so
when the pawn comes up Bishop takes
Knight doesn't work for white and
remember I said the bishops worst a
little bit more than the knight so the
correct move is just to retreat one
square but keep attacking the knight now
that pawn is very gives blacks
impossible move in the future when white
does threaten to take the knight and win
the pawn black will see that threat and
he can move this pawn here and drive the
bishop away from the knight the bishop
has to retreat here that's the reason
this is a good move for black so you'll
see that come into play okay
now this particular opening black now
plays move four he protects his key
center pawn remember the e5 pawn in this
is very important for black from a
defensive point of view it says
Center pawn he wants to defend that at
all costs and even if white attacks it
by say this pawn you don't do pawn takes
pawn you maintain the pawn and you let
white do pot and you take back keeping a
pawn on this square because it holds
back the white pawn and the pawn here
keeps this knight from going to this
square and it would keep any white piece
from going for this score cuz the pawn
can take of course diagonally right
similarly the white pawn affects this
square and this square and black can't
put pieces there so these pawns kind of
offset each other and it maintains an
equal position they call that a balanced
position in chess that means it's an
even position doesn't mean if the game's
going to be a draw it just means both
sides have chances to win as the game
develops but if grandmasters play it up
they head they don't make any mistakes
it should be a dry that's what balanced
game is okay now White's going to get
his King out of the middle of the board
and put it to safety and bring his route
to the center so White Castle see how
it's a little 0-0 symbol there move five
so that's how you write castles King
side and Queen side you just put a dash
in a zero and it's three and that would
mean Queen side of course neither side
can Castle queenside but white can
castle oh I wanted to mention one thing
there is a drawback to this defense it's
called the Steinitz
defense deferred named after a world
champ former world champion named
William Steinitz from Austria he
popularized this move they knew there
was a drawback to it it blocks the
bishop say the only square that Bishop
can go to is here but black is defending
anyway and this pawn chain this is
called a pawn chain when you get
reponse linked up is very strong
defensive setup so steinitz felt that it
was so strong it offset the fact that he
blocked the bishop but white of course
having the move it's very important to
get that bishop in front otherwise you
wouldn't have any attacking chances
anyway oh you guys know what a pin is
right a pin see how the bishop attacks
the knight and behind the knight is the
king you can't move the knight because
it would expose the King to a check
that's called a pin like pinning a piece
of paper on a notebook yeah it's called
a pin the pin in chess is one of the
most effective attacking it's an
attacking maneuver it immobilizes your
opponent's piece this Knight cannot move
once you pin a piece what you want to do
is you want to shove this pawn to this
square attack the pinned piece that
can't move and you could win the piece
with pawn takes Knight problem is white
doesn't have enough moves to do that it
takes two moves to go here and if white
moves here black just takes it and you
never get the pawn here so blacks safe
but blacks next move he's going to break
the pin do you know what break the pin
means
I know you want to put a piece in this
diagonal so the knight can move and
there's no check on the king so what's
the move to break the pin yeah but the
bishops just trade off they exchange
each other bishop for Bishop it's just a
fair trade
so that's why black now breaks the pin
and now his knight can move and does
once again defend the pawn is parking
pawn on e5 okay now this but there are
different ways to play this opening in
this game white plays pawn to Queen four
right away another option is to play
this pawn here first and then play the
pawn here that option has the advantage
that if like this pawn takes pawn the
pawn here takes back and you get two
pawns in the center and then you would
in fact be able to attack the knight by
pawn here and drive the knight back
that's that's an equally good opening
it's just a lot of times in chess you
have a choice between openings they're
both equally good it becomes a matter of
personal preference so in this case
white decided not to play c3 but just
play pawn to Queen for right away
okay now black
okay so white has two knights out I mean
a knight and a bishop out to pieces and
castling is also a developing move so
white hit end the pot he has two pawns
now black has two pawns in the center
the e5 in the d6 now they're not as good
as whites whites two pawns are on the
fourth rank right and this pawn is
attacking this pawn this pawn defends
this is an attack
now this one is can attack anyway white
has more space
and is attacking black is defending
that's because white gets the first move
and black has to defend patiently guess
how many moves you have to defend before
you actually get an equal position in
chef more like 15 to 25 depending on
which opening is played so some openings
really take a long time for black those
ones I told you about where the Queen
pawn and there's maneuvering that takes
sometimes 20 to 25 moves before it's
even now these are quicker King pawn
usually within 15 moves it's it's pretty
much resolved to an equal position or if
black makes a mistake then white gets a
an advantage but some kind of an
advantage 1 in tournaments let's say
there are a hundred people in the
tournament they rate up everyone has a
chess rating they rank him by the
highest to the lowest
they split the tournament in half they
took take the 50 highest and the 50 loss
and match them up so the highest guy in
the tournament plays the highest guy in
the bottom half the poor guy in the
bottom half gets killed so after one
round he has zero and the guy in the top
has one let's just say there's five
rounds games to the tournament well the
guy that you don't get eliminated now
all the guy who's second round all the
guys that won let's say 50 of them won
and 50 lost the 50 that one they get
they separated the fifty that one get
paired against each other the top half
of the 50 get paired to the bottom half
of the 50 now the ratings are closer
together the play the the top players
have to work harder to win the second
game now that the guy who lost he
gets paired against someone else who
lost now he's playing lower rated
players and he has a better chance to
get a win or a draw so if you hang in
there you you're likely to loot if
you're learning the game you'll be in
the bottom half of the tournament but
you lose tell one or two really good
players and then you're going to play
people your own level and you have a
very good chance of winning half of the
games and maybe coming in with 50% score
which is perfectly respectable when
you're learning how to play so that's
how that works and rating wise they take
the difference in the ratings let's say
I'm rated 2150 an expert rating and
let's say I'm playing a beginner that's
about 1600 which is the B player so my
rating there's four hundred five hundred
and fifty point difference I should win
that game
statistically well if I win the game I
only get like three or four rating
points added to my rating but if I lose
that game I may lose thirty or thirty
five points and my opponent because he
beats someone so much higher rated will
gain thirty five or forty points if you
play somebody at your same rating you
may only trade ten or fifteen points
either way and if you have a draw you
get half of that so that's that's
general and they have this complicated
mathematical formula does all this but
the statisticians and mathematicians
figured that out I don't mess with it
but anyway it is pretty accurate so
these guys vastly a bunch of 27:11 the
world champion class players in the top
twenty almost all are twenty seven
hundred and above grandmasters start at
twenty five fifty a young college guy
who makes Grandmaster
raided around 2,500 to 2,600 I'm a just
mastered the chess master starts at 2200
now I'm under that I've lost some a lot
of rating points to these younger kids
that gets so good you know and they they
steal my rating points by beating me
it's not really fair but just part of
getting older but anyway so it things
even out in tournaments so that's all
I'm saying
okay so anyway now but so black wants to
develop another piece well naturally his
night hasn't moved on the King side or
his black squared bishop so which of
those two pieces do you think he should
move the bishop or the night I agree
that's the right move why did you pick
the knight only one square that's true
and the knight move has a threat what's
the threat what would be that if black
can make two moves in a row what is
black threatening after he moves after
you move the knight to f6 remember it's
a three move l-shape he can go up two
squares and over one square to the from
black front of you to the right he he
attacks the e4 pawn doesn't it yeah so
you see if you have a choice
again you were right the bishop is a
lousy move and the knight is the better
it's better to get the knight out you
can always move the bishop later and the
night whenever you can make a move and
make a threat that's the move you want
to pick so that's the right move
now in this particular opening but white
decided to take the knight and black
took back now let's see what happens
this bishop and this knight are
threatening to win this pawn that's
unprotected so I guess the threat would
be Bishop takes Knight
you wouldn't do Knight takes pawn
I mean Bishop takes pawn you wouldn't do
Knight takes pawn why wouldn't you do
Knight takes pawn
if black could make an extra move well
why wouldn't you do Knight takes pawn
yeah and this pawn might move up here
driving the bishop away and the bishop
protects the knight if you do the bishop
takes pawn the pawn move doesn't attack
anything and the knight protects the
bishop and the bishop could take the
knight if if he should need to in the
future so he would that black would have
more possibilities by taking with the
bishop so that's the threat let's see
what white does white remember White's
castled so now he brings his rook over
to the middle of the board and he
defends this pawn here now it's true
that black has two pieces on the pawn
but it's also true that white can do
pawn takes pawn pawn takes pawn and
Knight takes pawn
so if black wins this pawn white wins
this pawn and this rook would be pinning
the knight against the King once this
pawn is gone and this Knight moves the
work that night this night would be
pinned to the King so it would be
dangerous for black to take the pawn
opening the rook file toward his King so
I'm sure well let's see what happens
okay black is not foolish enough to take
the pawn opening the work on his King
he's going to develop
bishop we talked about so you see
usually you develop your knights and
bishops before you mess around with the
rooks well first of all before you can
castle you got to move the knight and
Bishop out of the way right on either
side so it makes sense that you you move
your knight and bishops out before you
castle or move the rook so so that's the
right move he moves his Bishop to e7 now
White is going to develop and he has to
a knight and Bishop that haven't moved
yet what why don't you take a guess is
whether the bishop for the knight should
move where would you put the bishop yeah
you could go to g5 well III has a
problem III the only thing protecting
this pawn is what is this and if you
move here you blocked this from
protecting the pawn and he could just
snap it with Bishop takes pawn
so Bishop here is acceptable move it's
not the best move though what does the
bishop threaten here does he does he
threaten Bishop takes Knight but I told
you the bishops better than a knight and
the other bishop then gets a better
square comes up from the second world to
the third row where it protects the King
pawn so the bishop move doesn't really
threaten anything now don't forget
once black castles then he will threaten
Bishop takes pawn his only defended once
it's attacked twice the knight move has
the advantage of remember the Knights a
little slower so they often move the
nights before the bishops because the
bishops can move to a good square in one
move it takes the knight a couple
squares to advance in the black
territory but in this case the knight
move also protects that King pawn
a second time stopping the black threat
so the night move is the right move okay
now white is actually threatening to win
that pawn here by pawn takes pawn takes
Knight takes pawn because his funds
defended adequately because of this
threat black now feels he has to give up
his center pawn for this pot so that's
what he does see how it says he takes d4
remember our notation the e pawn takes
the d4 pawn now naturally the knight
takes back and threatens the bishop
now if white could make two moves in a
row white would take the bishop it's
worth more than the night and this pawn
would have to come here
now these pawns one in front of the
other there's a word for those in chest
you know what that is
double pawn so anytime the pawns see
they the pawn here blocks this pawn
doesn't it double pawns are weak in
chess you want to avoid double pawns if
you can sometimes you can't now there is
a plus two double pawns see how this if
this pawn was here see how it can't be
there's no pawn here or here this pawn
can't be protected by another pawn it
has to be protected by a piece so if
white could get his Queen here say it
would threaten Queen takes pawn and you
would tie black he would have to defend
by moving his Queen up to protect a pawn
and you really want to tie your Queen up
for ten
in a lousy pong you don't double pawns
are weak but they do have one advantage
if the pawn was here it guards the
center squared this night could not move
here because the pawn guards this square
so double pawns have a plus and minus to
it the minuses they're weak and can be
attacked and they're not defended by
other pawns
the positive is it was a beep on the way
back here in the second now it's a C
pawn on blacks third row and it guards
the key Center square that tends to
offset each other all right
anyway black he doesn't want to give up
his bishop he doesn't want double pawns
he retreats the bishop coincidentally
this Knight was threatening the hop here
this square was unprotected the bishop
move protects this square and if the
knight were to come here now black would
take the knight and look who gets double
pawn white and the double pawns would be
bad for white so he's not gonna move his
knight they're not for quite a while
anyway now this bishop here could come
here and attack the Queen
this Knight could come here and then
come back to the center square white
doesn't want either of those to happen
so he makes a preventive pawn move
remember I said you should develop your
pieces before your pawns so if you
follow that rule you'd move this bishop
now you could move to the square you
suggested right here cuz the pawns
defended by the knight and it doesn't
matter that the rooks block cuz the
pawns defended or you could move the
bishop here but again the bishop here
doesn't really threaten anything but
white chose to make it
a what's called a preventing pawn move
he moves the pawn here and see how it
guards this square so the bishop and the
knight can't go here so it's an
acceptable move in this situation is to
disregard the general rule of an opening
that you always move your pieces and you
don't make pawn moves in this case it's
a it's a decent pawn free of any move so
it's acceptable to violate that general
rule white plays h3 now black got all
his minor pieces he's ready to castle
and bring his rooks to the middle so
black castles and White's not sure where
he wants that Bishop to go yet so he
actually develops his queen and in this
case he puts it here now this is a good
Square for the Queen
it can't be attacked by any black pieces
because the only attacking square would
be here and that pawn move prevents that
the knight is attacking white scores but
can't attack the Queen the queen is
going to protect this square apparently
white wants to move the knight here the
knight here would attack this bishop in
this pawn and the queen protects it so
if the bishop took the knight white
wouldn't get double pawns he could take
with the Queen then he would have gotten
a bishop for a knight he would be happy
that he got a better piece for his
Knight and he didn't get double pawns
that's why he went Queen f3 he'll
develop this Bishop later on when it
becomes better more clear to him whether
the bishop should go here are there are
there are there so he's holding that in
reserve okay
black makes a minor mistake here he
plays his pawn here now every time you
make a pawn move it has plus and minuses
every pawn move creates weak squares
around the pond where the pawn was when
this pawn was here see how it guarded
this square and it guarded this pawn so
this pawn was rock-solid it's very safe
to have a pawn protected by another plum
that's a little pawn chain now the pod
moved here so this square is no longer
protected by a policy these this black
square and this pod is no longer
protected by a pawn this pawn is now a
little weak weaker than it was it is
protected by the bishop so White's not
gonna win it right no way but in the
future white can move this bishop here
see how it would attack the pawn he
might move his Queen here Bishop and
queen would then threaten Bishop takes
pawn he could swing this rook over here
attacking the pawn from here move the
knight over here to get out of the way
of the rook then they might have the
bishop and the Queen and the rook and
black might lose his key pawn that's why
this is a minor mistake but there's a
positive to it the pawn moved here and
now protects this key center Square and
the knight can't move up here plus and
minus but on the whole it's a minor
mistake because it weakened this key
pawn which more than offsets the gain he
got from protecting this square all
right let's so now white knows where to
put his bishop he has a target he's
going to target that weak pawn on d6 so
he immediately attacks the pawn
now black rather than he's good he
develops his Queen he counter-attacks by
bringing his queen along this diagonal
what does the Queen attacking from the
square this pawn notice that when the
bishop moved here that left this pond
unprotected black said well you might
win this pawn but I'm gonna threaten
this one and if this pawn moves here
when the pot is here it protects the
knight in this square if the pawn moves
here the knight is not protected by a
pawn and the Queen would have to protect
it that would give a target for the
Queen and maybe that black scored bishop
of attacking this knight at some point
the other thing the Queen coming up here
this rook can slide over here behind
this bishop the bishop can move back
then the rook and Bishop protect the
pawn and black thinks that's adequate
defense well I have a few more minutes
so we're not going to get through this
game but I want I wanted to explain the
opening principles to you okay now what
is the one piece that white is still in
its original position from white side
yeah where do you think he should so
that's the obvious piece that should be
moved where do you think white should
move it right here yeah you wouldn't
move it you behind the pawns that would
have no future but this is a great
square attacking that pawn like we
talked about and protecting the knight
at the same time because there is Queen
takes Knight as a threat
okay now black could take this pod I
don't know what this is but we're about
done anyway taking this pawn might not
be such a hot idea it would attack the
knight but the night is defend
by the Queen you see that so it doesn't
threaten Queen takes Knight and the
Queen can be attacked by what work move
the black Queen if the black Queen took
this pawn it can be attacked by a white
rook what's and where does the Queen go
the only squares here but look what's
undefended Whitewood get this pawn and
the rook would be attacking blacks back
row and hitting this bishop white would
be better because White's attack with
the rook is better than blacks Queen
doing nothing over here so black will
not take that pot not yet so black is
going to develop one of his routes to
the middle just like white did and in
this case he does the a rook and I won't
just do a couple more moves I'm going to
show you
white made ace not the best move here he
starts an attack with his King side pawn
now remember I told you these pawn moves
weaken squares so the pawn was here it
protected here and here moving up here
this pawn mouse can't be protected by a
pawn so this square in this square weak
and this square and this square are weak
see the squares around where the pawn
moved to but there is a threat white
wants to shove the pawn up here and
drive the knight back it's an attacking
move in this case is the dubious move by
white now my computer said oh the
computer programs are so good now
they're better than the world champion
and my program is called comedo that's
just the name of the people came up with
after a dragon you know the little
dragon a that's their emblem anyway it
says
white should have played queen here
protecting the night and let's see what
else we'll just run through this black
would play pawn up to c5 driving the
night away from the center of the board
the knight retreats you only retreat in
just when you're forced to
so don't voluntarily we retreat but in
this case he retreats and the knight
protects the other night so this Knight
protects this night and the knight can
reenter the game by coming up this way
so it's it may take a couple moves but
tonight it is still in the middle of the
board and can re-enter the game very
quickly now black develops his other
work behind there it protects the bishop
and the rook is lined up on the Queen
and on this pawn and the bishop can move
back and then black will counter-attack
with the knight and work on this pawn
and also keep this pawn from advancing
so that's why they did that now white
plays pawn to Bishop three so he finally
had enough of the Queen takes pawn
possibility so he stops it forever with
this move now black now that the Queen
has no longer attacking the pawn he
moves the Queen here where it attacks
the knight
it doesn't threaten to win the knight
but it does tie down the Queen and in
the night at least one of these two
pieces has to stay here and protect the
knight so it got the Queen to ask where
it attacks this Knight and it ties down
at least one of these two pieces and
then white well I told you the knight
can re-enter the game he comes up here
and at some point he can come back up
here and he protects this pawn and the
computer says that white has a slight
advantage anyway well in here this is
again the Rory Lopez this is the Stein
its defense deferred and we went over
the main opening principles of rapid
development controlling the center with
your pawns and your pieces okay thanks
thanks for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]